two things they can't really grow facial
hair and they don't have any smell to
their sweat that's true that's an enzyme
thing absolutely true and we don't have
Brazilian butts you do have Brazilian
butts you you seen a Korean with a
Brazilian butt Brazilian butts are oh
you're talking about BBL or just a big
butt big the kind the Brazilians have
she's a big butt then the thing is with
Koreans men and women have the same butt
you can't tell a man from a woman from
the butt you can in other cultures but
not Korean it's true what it is at least
in South Korea I don't know North Korea
they don't have footage let me just show
so what you're
yeah let's be honest yeah I'm serious
all right yeah so um I don't want to do
this did you hear his voice sit here
come on Don get on sit here so you're at
a Korean strip club yeah you have no
idea what's going on don't look above
the can I can I get some um strip club
music
[Laughter]
please
everybody he real rob it